il vient à peine une semaine des
partisans de donald trump envahissait le
capitole le pays a été choqué par ces
évènements et les représentants doit
maintenant voté le lancement d'une
procédure de destitution contre 2 valve
trump afin de le mettre en accusation
devant le congrès c'est la deuxième
procédure de destitution contre de la
halle trump et le chef d'accusation est
incitations à l'insurrection
donald trump maintient qu'il s'agit
d'une chasse aux sorcières
il ne respecte pas la procédure et
considère qu'il s'agit d'une persécution
c'est le point de vue de donald trump
sur la question donald trump est
beaucoup critiqué du côté républicain
beaucoup de républicains de
conservateurs ont déclaré qu'ils se
joindraient aux efforts des démocrates
contre donald trump pour le mettre en
accusation lancer une procédure et
peut-être même aller jusqu'à la
destitution comme l'a affirmé la
représentante républicaine liz cheney
donald trump est le troisième président
de l'histoire des états unis à être
soumis à une procédure de destitution
pour le président andrew johnson la
procédure a été lancée mais n'a pas
abouti
une procédure de destitution a également
été ouverte contre bill clinton après le
scandale monica lewinsky sans aboutir
non plus donald trump avait déjà été
soumis à une procédure de destitution
suite à sa discussion téléphonique avec
le président ukrainien
il s'agit de sa deuxième certains se
demandent si donald trump pourrait être
le premier président à quitter le
pouvoir suite à une procédure de
destitution
richard nixon a démissionné lorsqu'on a
lancé la procédure à son encontre
il a donc quitté le pouvoir avant que la
procédure ait véritablement commencée
donald trump devait quitter le pouvoir
le 20 janvier lorsque joe biden prêtera
serment en tant que président la
démarche est donc surtout symbolique
les démocrates disent qu'ils souhaitent
cette destitution afin que donald trump
ne puisse plus jamais être candidat 2
-s'il éligible à la présidence c'est un
moment important
historique au capitole le congrès
réagissent très fortement aux événements
d'il ya une semaine la soins du capitole
par des manifestants pro tron des
tensions sont toujours très vive dans le
pays dans le sillage des événements de
la semaine dernière
il reste à voir si cela mènera à la
destitution et au départ de donald trump